[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition du sky échos
le magazine qui vous racontent la vie
des acteurs économiques du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
pour cette nouvelle émission nous sommes
chez le constructeur automobile suédois
volvo et plus précisément chez volvo
construction équipement spécialisé dans
les engins de travaux publics
sa filiale française est implantée à
trappes et elle recherche actuellement
deux nouveaux collaborateurs
vous découvrirez cela dans ce huitième
numéro du sky échos
la stratégie du groupe renault a été
présenté le 14 janvier dernier dans les
annonces le programme software
république un plan déployé au
technocentre de guyancourt
la filiale française de volvo
construction équipement est implantée à
trappes spécialisé dans les engins de
travaux publics
elle recrute des mécaniciens découverte
de cette activité
enfin rencontre avec hugo line solaire
dirigeante de la start-up break norrec
une entreprise engagée dans la
transformation de déchets plastiques en
un matériaux réutilisables
[Musique]
le directeur général du groupe renault
lucas demeo a présenté le 14 janvier
dernier
le plan stratégique du groupe baptisé
renault lution une orientation produire
moins de véhicules mais de meilleure
qualité
quatorze nouveaux modèles seront lancés
d'ici à 2025
et parmi les propositions impactante
pour le technocentre renault de
guyancourt
le programme software république les
détails dans ce décryptage
[Musique]
d
et
ciao
[Musique]
implanté depuis sa création attrape le
site de volvo construction équipement
france est spécialisé dans les engins de
travaux publics maintenant est vantée
pour en parler nous sommes avec le
président de volvo c e des ligues marc
bonjour bonjour alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer concrètement
qu'est ce qui se passe à trappes eh bien
on est sûr trappe
le siège de la marque de la filiale
volvo construction équipement donc
marque suédoise et on dirige l'ensemble
des opérations en france la partie cells
and services et donc on pilote tout un
réseau de concessionnaires et on se
présente en gros 7 800 personnes sur le
sur les réseaux france et en plus on a
quelques activités supports notamment
entrepôt pièces de rechange et une
grosse succursales qui gère l'ensemble
du secteur grands pas ici il y as encore
à 140 collaborateurs s'est bien séparé
fectivement avec une partie atelier donc
qu'est-ce que c'est en fait qu'est ce
que c'est les engins de travaux publics
alors c'est vrai que volvo on a
l'habitude de
voir la voiture le groupe volvo à un
certain nombre de business area
différentes donc le camion qu'on connaît
un peu plus classiquement et la partie
tp donc sur la partie tp on a les
machines qui sont ce qu'on appelle des
machines de production donc tout ce que
vous allez retrouver en carrière donc
pour venir faire des trous transporter
les cailloux des agrégats etc
et puis après plus classiquement aussi
des machines un peu plus petit que vous
avez retrouvé sur sur la partie urbain
des mini-pelles mini chargeuses pour
faire le travaux de voirie ou alors
après si vous voulez creusez vous même
votre propre piscine vous avez la
possibilité de aussi avoir des machines
volvo actuellement vous êtes en phase de
recrutement
alors on il ya une crise sanitaire et
une crise économique et pourtant vous
recrutez ray effectivement l'année pour
nous 2020 a été on va dire en trois
phases
ça fait suite à trois quatre années où
les marchés bâtiment travaux publics
était plutôt sur des belles tendance
2016 2019
on a commencé la première phase 2020
comme on avait fini 2010 neuf donc sur
une très très belle dynamique
naturellement on a subi de plein fouet
le confinement le premier qui était
naturellement pas prévu sur lesquels il
a fallu qu'on gère comme tout le monde
donc on s'est complètement arrêté et
puis en fait depuis le mois de juin on
est sur une tendance où les activités
sont en train de reprendre alors avec
des grands enjeux autour des des
chantiers dans les régions mais on a la
chance d'avoir notamment sur le grand
paris un gros gros projet grand paris
express et donc on a retrouvé une
cadence quasiment quasiment similaire à
l'avant crise on a fait une fin d'année
plutôt plutôt très correct donc on a
repris notre notre démarche de
recrutement et notamment sur la partie
mécaniciens mécaniciens pour le mans et
justement on va les rencontrer un de vos
collaborateurs mécanicien référent
technique sur le site de trappes pour
découvrir en quoi consiste l'activité de
mécanicien sur les engins de travaux
publics
[Musique]
et nous avons rejoint christophe
garnotel bonjour bonjour vous êtes
référent technique sur le site de
trappes de volvo construction équipement
[Musique]
alors en quoi consiste le métier de
mécanicien sur l'étrange un de travaux
de public
comme nous avons derrière nous la alors
contrairement aux idées reçues c'est
vrai que on pense toujours technicien
faire des vidanges changer les ampoules
je pense que maintenant c'est révolu
même si c'est toujours d'actualité de
faire des vidanges
c'est quand même beaucoup plus poussée
on part maintenant sur delà du
diagnostic en électronique en
pneumatiques hydraulique la motorisation
thermique et bientôt maintenant de la
machine 100 % électrique quelqu'un un
mécanicien traditionnelle qui s'occupait
de voitures peut intervenir sur ce type
de danger alors en suivant des
formations en ayant des bases techniques
en automobile il peut très bien basculer
sur deux sur des travaux publics
bien sûr on souvent des formations un
peu plus poussées sur sur la gamme de
produits quel est le parcours
traditionnel chez volvo construction
équipement
alors si je prends mon exemple par
exemple je suis j'ai fait un bep en deux
ans en alternance chez volvo
j'ai enquillé sur un bac pro en deux ans
j'ai eu l'opportunité d'être embauché au
sein d'ateliers pendant 3 ans en tant
que mécanicien de maintenance mais
atelier puis passé en tant que
dépanneurs pendant sept ans sur la route
donc là me déplacer chez les clients et
dépanner machine sur site et depuis
bientôt deux ans maintenant j'ai intégré
les bureaux à trappes et je suis sûr
référent technique donc je suis en
support pour les techniciens ateliers et
sur la route
l'activité je suppose qu'elle ne cesse
d'évoluer exactement ça n'arrête pas ça
n'arrête pas toujours toujours une
remise en question parce que les
produits évolue la gamme évolue les
technologies évoluent donc toujours sur
sur le qui vive pour pour être
opérationnels et c'est pour ça que vous
êtes en phase de recrutement en ce
moment exactement
merci christophe garnotel pour nous
avoir fait découvrir ce métier de
mécanicien
et justement si vous êtes intéressé par
ce poste ce type d'activité n'hésitez
pas à vous rendre sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
[Musique]
et je vous propose maintenant de prendre
la direction de plaisir et de plonger
dans le secteur de l'économie circulaire
avec l'entreprise avec norrec cette
start up a été créé en 2018 elle
fabrique un matériau à partir de déchets
plastiques
elles entrent actuellement dans sa phase
d'industrialisation c'est ma vie
d'entrepreneur avec hugo line solaire la
dirigeante de cette société
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis maudit solaires sur la
fondatrice de rec norrec une start up
social à vocation industrielle qui
développe une solution dans le domaine
de l'économie circulaire et du recyclage
des plastiques
[Musique]
on y produit une nouvelle matière une
meilleure eco responsable qui remplace
le bois ou le béton uniquement à partir
des déchets plastiques qui échappe aux
filières de recyclage on les incorpore à
des proportions variées au sein de notre
recette et on va les broyer on va les
mélanger entre eux on va les passer dans
notre process thermomécanique pour en
faire une matière épaisse mais fluide
qui prend la forme des moules dans
lesquels on va la passer
[Musique]
quand on montrait des planches donc des
objets bien plat on peut l'utiliser
comme bois à l'extérieur parce que c'est
un matériau imputrescible et qui se
travaille avec les mêmes boutiques le
bois quand on en fait des objets moulés
on peut en faire des gros objets façon
béton ou des objets qui d'habitude sont
réalisés en plastique pour des usages
extérieurs
spécialité c'est d'un côté bas les
masques pas les masquer une opération
expérimentale de mise au point de notre
solution à court avec appliquée
spécifiquement aux masques et de l'autre
c'est la préparation de notre
démonstrateur avec un démarrage de levée
de fonds où on propose à des
particuliers de rejoindre le capital et
des investisseurs plus institutionnel de
financer les investissements conséquents
pour lancer cette cuisine
[Musique]
et avant de conclure cette émission
voici la nouvelle promotion des startups
du ski cube l'incubateur du territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines
elles sont au nombre de quatre avec
différentes activités une application
dédiée à l'iss porte une application
pour collecter les données financières
faciliter aussi la traçabilité des
activités agricoles ou encore un
logiciel pour faciliter l'organisation
du travail les détails dans cet instant
ico
non
[Musique]
l'incubation ou vise à accompagner des
porteurs de projets de startups combien
de jeunes startups
il y des êtres de tester éprouvé et
validé la proposition de valeur que le
modèle économique pour ensuite bâtir une
feuille de route ou un plan
développement pour ces startups
l'accélération elle vise à accompagner
des start up qui ont déjà du chiffre
d'affaires déjà de clients référence
qu'on appelle une traction de marché
habré et d'objectifs de l'être deux
d'accélérer en fait la croissance le
développement commercial
[Musique]
les objectifs pour moi de l'accélération
et de l'accompagnement vias qui cube
c'est d'être épaulé être épaulé sur
différents aspects du développement de
l'entreprise
quand on est un entrepreneur comme moi
ont extrêmement engagée pour servir le
client mais on a vraiment le la tête
dans le guidon en permanence c'est la
fin de ce numéro merci de l'avoir suivi
émission que vous pouvez revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile tv 78 à bientôt sur
nos antennes
[Musique]